we produce
pet food
for cats and dogs
and we are on the market already from
year 2003
we would like to change how people are
treating pets
[Music]
this
place is a dog friendly office
the philosophy is to be open and to be
dog friendly every day and every night
[Music]
it started in the beginning of 2000s
from my father's idea the core question
was we need to find the high quality
product we need to find the business
which which is
growing
in the world not only in ukraine and we
need to find business
uh without any production capacities in
ukraine so we would be the first
that's why the idea to produce a pet
food cane
we have been ranked 61 among the biggest
companies in the world in the pet food
we
are
fifth fastest growing company in terms
of turnover
in the world in pet food our team is
1000 people from which 85 percent are
pet parents
this is one one more worker
this is my dog house please meet him
he's a nine year old west highland white
terrier
and he's very friendly he never he'll
never bite
every third
pet is eating our product
from the pets which are eating ready
food
we have three factories
we produce more than 60 000 tons of
ready food
we are leaders in ukrainian market
[Music]
actually it was not growing fast we
didn't we didn't understand at the time
that people were not
were not ready to take the food which
was produced in ukraine that's why
uh first
five to six years we didn't make any
profit
we just were producing
the food the high standards and we were
speaking with the people we were
entering zoo shops we were speaking with
the end consumers and so on but now it's
growing
and after year 2008 we started to be
more aggressive and more
powerful
um then afterwards we started to export
and it helps us that we were under
european standards it helps us to
present our product
[Music]
we are exporting
to a big number of countries
this is a very special place for us this
is a map of the world now we are
presented in 37 countries
and we are planning to expand of course
home market is ukraine
and now we are selling 80 of our
turnover we are selling in ukraine but
20
are in all the
european and not only european countries
blue color is our home market where we
started and there is one more blue which
got a blue color last year because we
opened the factory in lithuania
so the places where we have our own
facilities our own factories
we are calling them our home countries
we always asking our client as we are
marketing company we are marketing and
production company we produce our own
brands so we are not playing
with the price we are playing with the
idea we are playing with the needs of
our clients
that's why i would say we can win the
market
[Music]
being socially responsible
it's a commitment
it's the things that changes the company
[Music]
we started in 2013
with
take your dog to work day here in
ukraine then we had a huge program
of help
for pets who were abandoned in the war
zone on donbas
[Music]
we are partners with lav since 2015.
since then every cat and dog
that lives here temporarily
eats our premium pet food
i say temporarily because they do aim to
find a new home for every cat and dog
that's here
so we do support also this adoption
that's why we give as a present a box of
a new owner
every new
owner of pet or a dog from here gets a
special box with pet food and some
manual how to treat pet
[Music]
we believe that
changing a world around you
changes you at the same time
[Music]
we are not building our business to sell
it we are building our business for
families we are family business me
personally and my sister we want to
give our company to our kids how this
company will look like under their
supervision i don't know
but i hope that it will live
much more longer than then i will live
ukraine is a big is a huge market
with much more bigger potential than it
is now
[Music]
another point
the knowledge of the people the
knowledge of ukrainians
is very high we are very educated people
ukrainians
are more happy
to produce something with the added
value
they
like to win the world
they uh
as they were living in soviet union
now they they would like to enter the
european
uh the european union they have european
values
this is the european country that's why
we gladly entering some markets with
premium products with added value
products and so on
[Music]
we would like to change the attitude
between pets and people
in
eastern europe our partners pets cats
and dogs
they
will not eat
not good product
not quality product you cannot play with
them they are not people
which which can eat something and then
can take some medicine
and they are okay with pets
it's not the game which which which you
can play with them
[Applause]
[Music]
you